foreign
[Music]
good evening fam thanks for coming
um long now if you have any extra room
in the mountain we have some film we're
trying to find room for I don't know
just a thought thank you for coming it
makes me incredulous to see so many
people and it's a wonderful feeling so
this year's program is called Bay and
Gateway past glimpses and possible
Futures It Centers on San Francisco and
the bay with a lot of amazing new images
but it makes some excursions out into
the state especially to trace
infrastructure and resources that in one
way or another link back to San
Francisco so two things number one you
know this is your event I encourage you
to make the soundtrack be loud you know
if you want to shout through your mask
that's okay too talk to your neighbors
dispute with them if you may
every event is different and it's
because of you I want to just say one
thing about One Clip towards the end
we're going to have a clip about a Vijay
day on Market Street in 1945 this is a
clip that has been shown piecemeal but I
don't think it's ever been seen on the
big screen in its entirety it's it's a
clip that contains violence that implies
sexual assault and shows some of it I'll
let you see it but it's about a really
tough event in the history of San
Francisco there's a lot of toxic
masculinity at the end of the war but I
think people should see it and I just
want to warn any of you I'll let you
know when it's coming in case this is
something that you don't want to look
full on at anyway 74 minutes have a
great time see you afterwards thanks so
much for coming
San Francisco
[Applause]
foreign
Boyce the maker of this wonderful little
trailer
[Applause]
foreign
California
next year the film will be entirely made
with sand
somewhere down south
Richmond
Bridge Bay Bridge
no zipper
I haven't figured out where this is
it was shot for the for the dust you
know not for the to record history I
think
this this is our early 70s
from a film called moods of the city
thank you
from footage shot by the State
Department of Education in the 70s
Central Valley
and this is about
1947-ish 49ish
thank you
we've jumped in time
the debut of a futuristic garage calls
forth full Civic panoply with mayor Elma
Robinson cutting the ribbon to open the
four million dollar structure for
business and why not the parking problem
being the same headache in San Francisco
is everywhere else a giant garage with a
capacity of 1200 cars fills a crying
need it's a sort of motorist maze you
park yourself just spiraling along the
in-ramp up and up and up until you reach
an open level and there you are another
ramp makes exit just as easy simple as
can be all was needed was four million
dollars at a stroke of Genius and the
parking problem is licked for 1200 Lucky
San Francisco drivers
[Music]
oh
my God
participatory tourism
after this footage was lost for some
years it's been found and it was newly
scanned in 4k and you know of course it
reminds me of the of the unparalleled
wonderful 1906 film down Market Street
but uh this is the cable car uphill
there's some interesting action in the
periphery a few
keep your eyes peeled
the former SF State Extension
and this is early to mid 60s I don't
have an exact date
thank you
foreign
foreign
is it just me or does it seem like
there's a lot more red in the city in
those days
now you know the cars are silver or
white
foreign
part this film is a bit of a tribute to
the amateur Cinema clubs of San
Francisco we'll be seeing a lot more of
them as time goes on this is from a film
um made about the Salvation Army's work
and this is south of Mark at the area
third and Howard fourth and Howard which
a few people remember is actually was a
Greek neighborhood as well as a
neighborhood frequented by older people
pensioners people
who might be experiencing Addiction in
one one form or another people who are
part of a casual Workforce Working Class
People couldn't
afford other neighborhoods but it was a
living neighborhood and
destroyed of course by Redevelopment
south of Market alleys before they were
monetized
and some Street Scenes you could tell
this one because they're selling the
Berkeley Barb
[Music]
ARA late 60s
what was the Berkeley Barb that was a
radical underground newspaper coming out
of Berkeley there was also the tribe but
Berkeley Barb was kind of a signal of a
certain kind of
my political stand which in a lot of
ways doesn't really exist in the same
way anymore
Montgomery Street oh these people are
taking a test for a punched card
accounting
the information economy a few years back
and during the 1964 Democratic
Republican convention Goldwater was
nominated here in San Francisco and the
Civil Rights Movement made their uh made
their position very very clear
[Applause]
mind Mill a union identified with a
Communist party for many years
okay
another left-wing Union that was closed
down and of course the ILWU
kept the tradition of Labor solidarity
alive for years
now you may think you've seen this
before but you haven't this is another
take recently discovered
hold on to your masks
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Echoes of 1906 as fire apparatus races
through San Francisco streets and debris
litters the sidewalks a series of
earthquakes lasting almost 48 Hours
starts numerous small fires and causes
tall buildings in the downtown area to
sway thousands of store windows are
shattered showering glass into the
streets in markets cans by the tunnel
are catapulted from the shelves in all
seismologists record 15 shocks one of
high intensity in large apartment
buildings Windows particularly in the
upper floors are again the casualties
suburban homes are shambles as furniture
and kitchen equipment are turned into
piles of debris on the floor within 150
mile radius bridges are shattered a
400-foot stretch of highway slides into
Lake Merced millions of dollars in
damage is the toll as San franciscans
brace for further Tim Lords
epicenter Daly City
and this is a recent discovery this is a
film shot inside of Little Joe's
Restaurant
sometime in the 70s
[Applause]
some of you remember that restaurant
remember the guy with his gun and all
that stuff
um this was uh this was formerly owned
by uh Franco
montanello and we're going to see him in
here as well he died in 2016.
but the restaurant was was in North
Beach for 20 years
it's just people cooking and eating by
the way that's all
uh every so often things would get a
little raucous and Little Joe's and
that's kind of a joke the the the
manager the owner would like lift up his
uh apron and you would see that he was
carrying
and you know the whole thing about this
restaurant right is observation you
watch them cooking you watch other
people eating as you wait behind them
and we're watching all of them
not on OpenTable
foreign
just a few
that's Frank
and some new footage of the Montgomery
block uh torn down for the Transamerica
Pyramid
this was small businesses and uh
uh import stores and a lot of artist
Studios this was a key epicenter of San
Francisco art in the 30s 40s 50s maybe
even later
the Imports
uh-huh
thank you
and this by request we've seen this
before once or twice this is dancing on
the street in the Barbary Coast probably
Jackson Street there's been some uh
people who've um attempted to identify
some of these dancers because they're
known in the world of Showbiz but I I
don't think that that's conclusive yet
and this is uh said to be about 1914.
beautiful shot
thank you
[Applause]
and a little later this is uh Purcells
on Pacific Street of black and tan Club
founded by Lou Parcell and Sam King who
had been Pullman Porters this was a taxi
dance club you'd pay a token to dance
with somebody
um this is the San Francisco's Repertory
Cinema that sento cedar in the early 60s
just a few little shots there the bridge
now the baseball academy on Geary
and um
probably the tohu Touhou
known as the kokusai gehio Gucci almost
also as well
and you know that
the Goodman building on the left artist
Studios for a while and look how many
bison
[Music]
[Applause]
the lonely boat
and a church picnic this is still awake
I wish they put these back in service
sort of atomic fish
much wider range of watercraft than now
the historic Bridge
and um
this is uh quite an unusual array of
birds I gather the gulls that weren't
present anybody want to talk about this
now yeah
but from a species distribution point of
view this footage is actually quite
important
we recently discovered this film was
made in 1947 the house still looks much
the same
in fact I'm going to drop a DVD down
there in the next week or so just so
they could see their house
and this is a wedding we haven't been
able to figure out the family name I've
looked and looked and looked
hmm
this is for the San Francisco neon
people if you're here the 76 Union Tower
at first and Harrison
[Applause]
[Music]
seventh and mich 7th and Market
and from another source
[Music]
all right whoever can guess this first
yes what day is it
good guess but I you can't guess what's
going to happen
oh my God
okay
all right
there's a metaphor for you
this was the relatively short-lived
seaplane fairy you can see why
and between 1939 and 1958 for 42 cents
you can take a train across the bay
bridge and um here is the journey
on The Late lamented Key System
the AC Transit lines I think a through F
and one other one
were trains across the bridge
and then fanned out
throughout the East Bay and the lower
deck you see the trains a load for
trucks a land for trucks and a passing
Lane which apparently was um two-way you
took your life in your hands
the World's Fair of course 1939
these were torn up you know when the
company that uh uh ran key system was
bought up by national city lines which
was in part owned by General Motors and
tire companies that didn't want to
encourage public transportation but the
other part of it is that ridership
dropped and dropped and dropped by the
end it was 5 million a year which wasn't
enough to to sustain this and it didn't
have a a subsidy
so we're coming into the
building that I'm not nostalgic but I do
miss the transbay terminal in some ways
foreign
Force Transit
terminal
yeah
first in Mission
built in 1941.
this is a new high-resolution scan of a
newsreel that was probably shot by the
veteran the camera person Frank Vale
this is um along around Oxford Street in
Berkeley your um Oxford and Hurst
and uh it was a
a real major fire what always hits me
about this is sort of it's a bit
carnivalesque as well
1923
be decorating a press house
and there's somebody waiting for the
train in Berkeley and in a minute this
is the inside of the key system train
just before they close down
I repeated it because it's a really rare
image
could look right out front
and here's
tying up a freighter
in the 70s
I love this uh this clip
Port of Oakland
[Music]
take two
right there
and uh
in downtown east side of downtown in
Oakland the beautiful thyme gasoline
and this is a piece of footage that just
recently was um scanned I think we're on
the Railroad and we're in um
uh probably El Cerrito
coming in
coming south towards Berkeley and
Oakland this could actually be uh from a
camera car it's um sometime in the 30s
or 40s I haven't done my research on it
yet but it's those um East Bay Hills
when they're still kind of almost
semi-rural
uh and it's this is an area that I'm
really interested in because of what
happened in Richmond you know during
World War II the incredible expansion
and also um this area El Cerrito uh uh
Albany was also a in the unincorporated
part was also uh see the fur doctor in
San Francisco
um was also a Haven for organized crime
for vice for gambling for bootlegging
illegal dance clubs as we will soon find
out but this area now is all completely
built up I believe that we're coming
into
somewhere near Albany
as you will see
I think that we're a little too close to
the uh walk to the Bay San Pablo Avenue
you get is a strip uh in the background
and this I think may be a shell Mound a
midden uh created by indigenous people
in that area which now has probably been
built upon
I don't think it's Berkeley I think it's
further north I could be wrong I don't
think this is the you know the famous uh
Berkeley or Emeryville shell Mount I
think this might be Albany Hill
but uh you know this will be online so
you can look and this is uh one of my
favorite pieces of film this is Arnold
Molina who in San Jose is still riding
bareback
and uh and and keeping his community and
nation's Customs alive
[Music]
and this is Rancho San Pablo this is a
nightclub and Casino in El Cerrito
um it's it's built in the Castro Adobe
which was built by indigenous labor in
the 1830s the Castro's had a Mexican
land grant 19 000 Acres
um
in the 30s El Cerrito became a place for
a dog racing uh uh track gamblers
there was money from the track and then
a racketeer named Big Bill petrard took
the Castro Adobe and opened up a
nightclub called Rancho San Pablo right
after prohibition with card tables
roulette slot machines and big name
entertainers and it was also uh
was
a place where there are no rules and
here's some mom except Mob Rules and uh
here's uh some footage shot by some
people who are close to the uh you know
the Performing Community there this is
the kitchen and maybe the boss or maybe
a guest star
and this is all about 1938 to 1940.
after World War II there was the good
government League that some citizens
formed and they got they kicked gambling
out except for the card rooms uh further
up in San Pablo and then a dog racing
track was demolished for a drive-in
movie and then this building was
destroyed in an arson fire right after
preservationists had tried to say that
it suddenly burned up and it is now uh
uh El Cerrito Plaza
foreign
thank you
and the band
thank you
they are
we don't but I'm sure there's people in
the area who could identify everybody
some of the acts are identified
including this one
thank you
it looked like swear words to me
[Music]
okay
now for the first time ever on the big
screen the Oakland Dog Training Club
and there's about three quarters of an
hour of this so I just gave you the
obedience trial
most of them did pretty well
foreign
and we're at the Oakland train station
I believe it is 16th and wood and looks
like we're heading we're in the area of
Altamonte pass
Vista though
the first Amazon warehouse that was in
the Senate Tracy
and my geography's off here but this is
Modesto on a rainy day in 1952.
States
everybody
this is Modesto
I finished editing this over the weekend
when it was raining all the time so I
water was on my mind
California
you wonder when you look through home
movies a lot as we do white people shoot
what they shoot what's the motivation
for each shot and this film is really
puts that in the idea in the foreground
don't know where this is
[Music]
mom
foreign
and this we think is the Westwood Cinema
Club one of the many amateur Cinema
clubs in the Bay Area going to the
country for their Excursion
bring the family
and um
you know uh it's kind of fun I I don't
want to be a
a sore head here I think they're kind of
reenacting some of the well drinking the
drinking gasoline
reenacting some of their favorite
settler customs
uh but they're making a movie on the Fly
and and these films came from a
a wonderful horde from a man you may
know in San Francisco Michael Brown
I know lives across the street from one
of you who gave us some just incredible
stuff for this year
foreign
you see this you see some of the
Hallmarks of amateur Cinema which is
trying to tell a story you know cutting
between close-ups and long shots and
finding these moments and
what's a Cinema Club oh so um there were
Cinema clubs all over the world
um they tended to get together to look
at each other's movies to sort of have
an ethic of quality
uh and I think of sort of
professionalism within the amateur space
and they made many many interesting
films these are um home movies from the
family of Brandon Castro who I met when
he was finishing UC Santa Cruz he's now
in the MFA program at USC
uh and this is his family
he's not he's not born yet these are the
60s and we we scan this films for him I
mean he was born in the uh in the very
late to uh you know 1999 perhaps 1998
that says to hell with housework
right and this is sort of Thanksgiving
out of bounds
and some shots around East L.A where the
family lived at the time
and we think this may be the beginning
or the end of some kind of a March it's
not really clear
may just be people hanging out
but now
um we've seen a little bit of this
before and there's some new material
it's just a snippet but this was the uh
the the famous Chicano moratorium the uh
the demonstration against the Vietnam
war that took place in East Los Angeles
and uh it's uh it's known uh because of
uh
a man who was uh an L.A Times Reporter
who Reuben Salazar who was a sitting
inside a bar when the county sheriffs
came and shot it up and was lost his
life
uh but this is a historically very
significant moment when the Chicano
Community comes out against the Vietnam
War in 1970. Mr Castro became an
educator and a politician after uh after
being in the brown Berets which there's
a Brown Beret remember right there not
unlike the Black Panther Party this is a
clip we don't know who this family is
it's the late 40s they're in the process
of building a house on the east side of
LA and this is Mother taking the the
kids out where the snow-covered
mountains in the background and um
and they're looking over
the city of Los Angeles
you might think of that as sort of the
opposite of the conquerors gays or the
colonizers gays this I don't know
anybody help me this could this can't be
Signal Hill maybe it is but there's an
oil fire
uh By Night and somebody shoots
the oil fire because of course it's
really dramatic
could be in Torrance
right because I don't think there's so
many tanks up at Signal Hill but I'm not
sure
there aren't thank you
and then the morning after
what date is this we don't have a date
yet
looks like quite a spill actually
no this is down south
I don't think this is standard oil
enrichment
but I appreciate the thoughts and the
corrections you know like uh
Fox News we report you decide
this is what comes after the fire I just
had to leave it in
and here's the Sacramento River when
it's reaching or close to flood stage in
1940 and this is um a little movie that
was just given to us by our friend Greta
Snyder who teaches at San Francisco
State by some folks who are really River
conscious they were also in the gravel
business
very good business to be in by the way
and there's sort of a narrative here
he rescues that but somebody threw it in
are you thinking the big Causeway on
interstate 80. I don't think it's quite
as close to the city
I think this is further north
yeah it could be Colusa it could be I
there's writing around it that says
Kalama but I'm not sure this is near
there
I don't know Charlie Chaplin looked
about him isn't there
um
and a very brief clip of a celebration
of the history of the bicycle
here
and this is Seal Stadium
you all know now the site of the
Potrero mall and I just love people
running onto the field that's the only
reason this is here
let's take a moment to solemnly remember
the Double Play Bar
[Applause]
hmm
what part of the city so this is um is
uh is uh 16th between is it Bryant and
Potrero
or
yeah
beauty shop
the dam
foreign
and here's a family visiting from I'm
not sure where the woman who is driving
at the beginning
uh uh shot some of this
this is you know the three years after
the summer of love and it sort of shows
this is our driver from the beginning
presumably her partner
is up to something
huh
foreign
comes to the art school to teach a
younger generation the meaning and the
technique of his art
sprawling down one of the slopes of
Russian Hill with spacious Studios and
Gardens the California School of Fine
Arts is the second oldest art school in
America the very atmosphere of its
location overlooking the Latin quarter
and the bay is inspiring to young people
in their study of the Arts
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
the attraction of San Francisco which
has so much to offer in Cosmopolitan
spirit in Scenic excitement and in the
professional Excellence of its Major Art
School brings many hundreds of art
students every year from all parts of
the country to the Golden Gate
every branch of art is taught at the
California School of Fine Arts figure
painting and Ceramics fashion
illustration and life drawing interior
decoration and lithography sculpture and
advertising art metalwork and camouflage
and of course outdoor sketching allowing
the students to choose their own
viewpoints and let their imaginations
freely translate into sketches and
paintings what appeals to them and their
surroundings
the California School of Fine Arts
incidentally is not the only art school
in San Francisco there are others
specializing in advertising art fashion
design and other Allied Arts
few tools but skillful hands are needed
to learn the secrets of an art which is
as all the civilization
foreign
[Music]
food is served at the cafeteria where
scholarship students help behind the
counter
some eat their meals indoors against the
background of murals painted by students
themselves others take their trays to
the sunlit patio
[Music]
from the spring and Bloom Department
Hardware hats on Parade for 41 years
employees of a San Francisco hardware
store have been blossoming forth in the
spring with bizarre bonnets made from
products they sell in the store strictly
from stock strictly for labs mops work
gloves brushes water potpourri of Merry
millinery
the drinks are on me could be the name
of these silly Chef pose ideal for the
cocktail hour quite Chic so down the
head
you name it and you can wear it
strictly for the birds but not cheap a
good salesman could mop up selling them
and you all know when you get off the uh
the Central Freeway at Octavia you pass
the First Baptist Church
these are our home movies of
parishioners and shot outside Market
Waller and Octavia starting really in
the early 50s through the 60s and
um
take a look at the people but also at
the environment this is Old Market
Street
yes exactly
and a diner nearby
excuse me
is that the U.S Mint Hill in the
background
foreign
Street
foreign
billboard
somewhere in the neighborhood don't know
where and this is the Malcolm X Festival
which um it's not quite the same as the
festival that still continues in East
Oakland this is in Berkeley
it's a film that we found we don't know
what year and unfortunately we have no
sound
but uh take a look and celebrate
so it was various places
um and I don't I can't specifically call
this out I know that the first Festival
was in 1970 and they were annually up at
least through 75 and probably afterwards
just discovered this and just started to
do some research
and there's a the Jihad news Collective
shooting some video
foreign
and it's World War II we're in Southern
California
the automatic Screw Machine Company
and this is just some really gorgeous
footage of women workers doing light
Manufacturing
checking with a
a a tool the proper that these are meat
tolerances
the whole film is about accuracy making
good parts for the Navy
if you ever wondered
important
so the sequence that follows uh shortly
is the sequence that I mentioned to you
of uh of the Vijay day riots in San
Francisco on August 14 and 15 in 1945.
90 of the rioters were young enlistees
in the Navy who'd never been overseas in
two days 13 people were dead over a
thousand people were injured at least
six survivors of rape were treated at
Central emergency hospital there were
many more who never I think came forward
no one was ever charged no one was
punished the city swept us under the rug
it's
I mean to me it raises all kinds of
interesting questions about sort of
victory in a war and uh
well
um what that all means but I'm just
letting you know in case any of you
happen to find this disturbing it's uh
it's a tremendously interesting piece of
footage and it follows shortly
and this happened in most big cities but
it was nothing like nowhere else was it
like San Francisco
that's correct it's it's uh it's right
after the Japanese surrendered
and uh a few days after the
the atomic bomb attack on Nagasaki
um
the old newsreel theater
the reason it jumps in and out of focus
is because the film is um
uh shrinks Eve unevenly
thank you
foreign
foreign
uh people were run over people had
bottles thrown at them people fell off
of street cars and out of Windows
um some a couple people were knifed I
believe
was a variety of causes
and now for something I'll considerably
more life affirming
[Applause]
does somebody know when the first parade
was
71
right this was not even on Market Street
yet I think it's O'Farrell is it
laughs
you know what year this is Rick 75 end
of June
[Music]
sides
and the rally at City Hall afterwards
just a little sweet outtake from the
Giants Victory Parade sometime in the
60s
and this brings us
to an enigmatic end because this series
never really ends
out in the sunset somewhere
thank you
thank you
thanks to all of you and thanks to them
oh thank you
foreign
[Music]